can we talk about that little spark of
an idea you had I believe it was in your
hometown in Alabama before you came to
La what was that like well it's the it's
the feeling that every writer should
have when they think of an idea um in my
case I I couldn't even I think back on
it now and I don't know why it came to
me why I felt like it was why it got me
jazzed but for some reason I had an
image in my head when I was very young
and thinking may I I was loving movies
but I wasn't quite sure how to if I had
a place in the in the movie and
television industry but I had an it just
occurred to me wouldn't it be cool if
there was this married couple upscale
married couple in a beautiful home
they're both attractive well-dressed he
the the husband is dressed for work goes
out the front door because his wife
could by the door closes behind him and
we hear the voice over of a police
detective saying when was the last time
you saw your husband Mrs M offlin and
that was it that's all I I was like that
seems really cool I would want to watch
that movie why would a guy with a
perfect life seemingly walk out the
front door and never come back and uh
from that I built a detective story
which is called fourth story eventually
and uh structured it out I didn't know
what I was doing but I had seen a lot of
movies and I sort of cobbled together
what seemed like a cool detective story
and I eventually wrote it uh I came out
here to Los Angeles and went to a film
school and started comparing it with
other people's work and professionals
work and seeing what I'd done wrong and
how I could improve it and I rewrote it
many times the movie eventually was
bought and sold and optioned and uh I
rewrote it many times for different
directors and different actors and
eventually it got made years later um
but it all started with that spark and
that's true of every great film every
great film somebody's has a little
glimmer just a spark sometimes they
they'll share with us you know the the
writer um for example Brokeback Mountain
the uh she's not a screenwriter she's a
fiction writer Annie Pou was in a bar
and somewhere on the west and she's
sitting there and she's watching there's
a pool table and the young cowboy types
are playing pool and she looks over and
there the sitting at the bar as a crusty
looking older cowboy watching the
younger Cowboys play pool and it just
flickered in her head I wonder if he's
gay and suddenly given his age and where
she was in the time and place she
thought that means he would have come of
age probably in the 50s
1950s what would his life have been like
if she if he'd been gay if he is gay and
from that she structured a short story
called Brokeback Mountain which then was
optioned and became the film that we all
even people who've never seen the film
know the term Brokeback Mountain that's
how uh ubiquitous it became and uh that
was her her moment and I call it an her
moment you are it's just a term I came
up with it just means the beginning the
the the start of something the that
passionate flicker of excitement that uh
that that the original writer has and
then which is if you're lucky you get it
transferred all the way through the many
drafts and onto the screen obviously in
the case of something like Brokeback
Mountain it worked uh but every movie
has that thing and only the original
writer can track it down and actually
identify it unless they CH to share it
with us uh we don't usually know what
that moment was it very often isn't
necessarily the most famous scene in a
movie but it's it has to you need it to
be there you the writer have to have
that uh in order to get yourself through
this experience of writing a structuring
and writing a screen p is going to take
at the minimum weeks and usually months
if not years so you have to keep coming
back to that and saying what was it I
was excited about oh yeah that's what it
is and you keep breathing life on that
little Ember that uh that if you've done
it right still alive and it flickers to
life and it keeps you
going are we sharing that idea with
others
beforeand I I never share it nor should
anyone else that's yours to keep uh if
you try to share it in the and that's
our instinct when we're starting out I
got this idea for a movie and if let's
say I pitched what I just told you was
my uh my uh spark for a fourth story and
I shared that with somebody especially
somebody who wasn't a writer and of
course when you're starting out you're
usually surrounded by people who are not
writers not creative and they said I
don't get it what would that it doesn't
seem that interesting oh gosh I guess I
shouldn't write it so never share it
it's only yours no one else needs to
know it occasionally after a movie is
successful sometimes a screenwriter in
an interview or something will share it
uh Alan Ball shared his uh his spark
moment uh in in the series in the go
draft I call I call it the IR moment but
he shared it uh for American Beauty
which was him one day sitting I think it
was in New York and watching a plastic
bag Bob around in the wind and seeing
how beautiful it was and it's it was
prosaic and other people would have just
thought it was litter but to him he saw
the beauty behind it and from that
moment he structured the movie American
Beauty and that scene is still there uh
right to the it went through many many
many Dr
before it got made but that scene is
still there the scene that I described
about for story I rewrote that script
many times it was right there at the
very end it was still there the whole
time because it was the thing that got
me excited therefore it was probably
going to be the thing that got the
producers excited the director excited
the actors excited and ultimately the
audience excited if you execute it well
enough and do you find in this era of I
guess you for lack of a better word
oversharing
online in person wherever that it's hard
to hold on to that because we're we're
kind of conditioned now to show
everything online or even with strangers
wherever that it's hard to kind of keep
that ember private anymore uh it's not
hard for me but I'm not from that era of
social media and constant sharing so I
would imagine yes it probably is harder
than than one would think um I one piece
of advice is to never share anything
about your work with anybody until uh
unless it's unless it's a close personal
friend and preferably a close personal
friend who is a writer or an artist uh
but it's best not to share anything with
anybody unless it's in some sort of
professional condition so that's a St if
somebody says give me a log line for
your for the movie you're working on
don't just blurt something out think
about what that is think about what what
that one sentence or that elevator pitch
as they call it I used to call it a
party pitch you know when somebody say
hey what are you doing and especially if
you're in LA and you're might going to
meet actors and agents and producers who
knows where you're going to meet them
and you might get 20 30 seconds of their
attention hey what are you working on
you should have that party pitch down
tight so that you in in 20 or 30 seconds
before you lose their attention you're
presenting your idea in the in its best
possible light in a professional light
uh if you just go around blurting out
stuff uh you're doing more harm than
good most of the time uh the act of
presenting your material to a public
even if it's just one person at a party
presenting it uh should be taken
seriously um and same is true if you're
writing up a little treatment or a
two-pager description of your idea let's
say an agent or a manager somebody
producer has asked you for it take your
time make sure it's right it's better to
have it right than have it fast um and I
never ever ever ever send out a draft of
anything I don't want to share that
until I know it's my best work
uh the the the the test I used to use
and still do and advise other people to
do when you've gotten your draft to a
place where you think it's showable
sharable uh stop for a moment and
picture what if I send this out to
whoever my contact list is and it comes
back a negative respond and people say I
don't get it I don't like it how would
you feel would you feel obviously you're
going be disappointed but would you feel
disappointed and kicking yourself I knew
I should have not done another pass oh
God I why didn't I take a little more
time with that or would you say yeah I'm
disappointed but that's my best work and
and you know maybe the timing was wrong
or whatever the planets didn't align
this time I'm hurt but I'm okay I'll
live with that uh if that's the second
response is what you'd feel then it's
time for it to go out but if the first
response is what you'd feel don't send
it out look at it again you only get one
first impression so you don't want to
you don't want to misuse it and and
first impression too with the party
pitch even you're at a barue yeah you
can't go back and say oh wait a minute
what I really meant was you've lost them
already you get one shot so uh and if
you don't have it yet then just say oh
I'm working on a movie script uh maybe
I'll you know can I call you later and
tell you about it but there's other ways
to do it but don't present it until it's
ready to be presented or better yet but
go don't go to a party unless you
already have that in your head if
anybody asks me this is what I'm going
to say and think about it so it's as
tight and as hooky as possible so that
it makes them want to say oh that sounds
kind of interesting when you're done
with that give me a wringle you know
give me a jingle you know I'd like to
talk about it more um
that's what you really are going for in
those moments and those moments happen
more often than you might think which is
one of the reasons why most people have
to move to Los Angeles to to break in
because it's hard to do that if you're
living in Birmingham
Alabama